intermountain healthcare the sponsors of
this next segment support a very special
organization that gives our local kids
happy feet here's how
[Music]
hi i'm christina kober with under
mountain healthcare we're here today
with the goody two shoes foundation i'm
here with nikki bertie the ceo of goody2
shoes uh enter mountain recently had the
opportunity to sponsor one of the local
shoe distribution events so nikki if you
want to tell us a little bit about the
event about goody two-shoes foundation
sure i'd love to and we're super
appreciative of the support that you
guys have provided goody two shoes has
been outfitting children in need here in
clark county since 2003 we have
outfitted over a hundred and seventeen
thousand kids uh through the years of
doing shoe distributions we have a 48
foot mobile unit that we take to schools
we go to a different title one tier one
pre-scheduled school almost every week
we pull ups like a giant transformer
we have racks that come out and set up
and and
doors that open and then the kids are
pre-selected based on me we outfit about
120 to 150 kids every 30 minutes
one-on-one with a community volunteer
who takes them through to make sure it's
a properly fitting pair of shoes but the
crux of goody two-shoes programming is
to give the kids the opportunity to
select their very own brand new pair of
sneakers so they do that the volunteer
makes sure the shoes fit we also give
them six pairs of socks because years
ago we saw the kids didn't have socks as
well and then they'll check out we
double check to make sure it's a
properly fitting pair of sneakers they
check out so we do inventory control
they grab a dental kit because we saw a
lot of tooth issues going on
over the years and then they head back
to class a lot of people oftentimes
don't think about the need for shoes
and for families that are in dire
straits or lower socioeconomic
background
shoes are often something foregone to
rent or groceries and so it's really
important that kids have the proper
footwear to be able to go to school and
actively participate um
bad shoes shoes with holes duct taped
whatever can become a really big flash
point for bullying and ridicule and so
we want to make sure that we're boosting
self-confidence we're getting kids in a
properly fitting pair of sneakers so
they can actively be involved in the
school environment and they're not
thinking about shoes that are too small
or too big on their feet that they're
focused in the classroom for myself and
for my other fellow caregivers to be at
the shoe distribution event it was very
meaningful
we get to see an immediate impact take
away we got to see
the at the lights go into kids eyes when
they got to pick out a pair of shoes a
brand new pair of shoes for the first
time and so this was really meaningful
work and it just left a lasting
feel-good moment for many of our
caregivers to be able to volunteer and
see
some of the resources going to use in
this way volunteers are critical to the
work that goody two-shoes does we only
have a staff of four and so everything
that happens out in the community at
every school we visit is the
responsibility and the result of
volunteers stepping up to make a
difference in our community it's a
simple four hour commitment usually on a
friday morning at a different title one
tier one school there's great
opportunities to come out see the impact
such as your team did and come out and
make a difference and see those smiles
and see those shining eyes and those
happy faces and dancing feet
such a great organization thank you
intermountain healthcare for sponsoring
that segment for more information visit
goody2shoes.org
[Music]